THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS  T.
D WAS CONNECTETO ER AMBR MARI
YANOVICH.
HER AS
THE U.S. AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE
INAN SHE IN E IMHMIR
WAS ON TWITTER AAC HERT
THAT VERY MOMENT.
G TO THE "NEW YORK
RUDY ULIANI
CONNECTION TRYIN
IDULIANI WANTED R FIRE WHOSE
DIRECTION?
RMER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS?
G TO PLAY BOTH
TTHS TO ANSWER THAT KEY
QUESTION AS CNN'S JESSICA
>>HNEIDEPORTS.
THE INVEATION INTO RUDIANI AND
INVESTIGATORE SECHE "NEW YORK T
WARRANTSD ST
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE, MARIE
YANANOVI WHOFIED IN THT IMPEACH
>> OUR UKRAINE POLICY HAS BEEN
THROWN INTO DISARRAY ATHE WORLD
OES NOT GIVE THE WORK.OR
TO GET OUSTED
BENEFIT TOP  BENEFIT
IT'S ALL PART OF THES.UGHT
NAL
INVESTIGATION INTO GIULIANI AND
FON E WHILE HE
ALSO SERNGS AL ATTOR
FEDERAL AGENTS SERVED A SEARCH
HISMENT AND
OFFICE WEDNESDAY SEI SEVERAL
DEVICES.
>> ABOUT 6:00 IN THE
THERE WAS A BIG BANG, , BANG
OOR AND OUTSIDE WERESEVEN, SEVE
ANT FOR ELECTRONICS.
I'VE OFFERED T TO
THE GOVERNMENT AND TALK IT OVER
TH THEM TWO YEARS.
DO THEY HAVE TO DO
TH.
E ENWHAT
OGETIC, I MIGHT SAY.
>> Reporter: GIULIANI INSISTS
HE'S NEVER ACTED AS A FOREIGN
AGENT.
>> I'VE NEVER REPRESENTED A N NL
TED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
I'VELI SEVERALIMES
I'VE HAD CTR IN COUNTRIES
KE THE UKRAINE.
IN THE IS A CLAUSET SAYS I
WILL NOT ENGAGE IN LOBBYING
FOREIGN REPRESENTATION
IT BECAUSE  IULD BE TOO COMPRO.
>> ReporI WAS A
RME BIDEUKRAINE. OATED FALSE
>> ARIMES THATHECRATS COMMITTED
ASTO, AND  SAY
JOE BIDEN WAS THE
THE BRIBE AND  THE BRIBE IN
OTHER WORDS TO PROTECT
RUDY GIULIANIAS
REPEATEDLY ASKED LAST NIGH
TH CL PROBE COULD
JUSTHAT
LE VIOLATION OF THREIGN AGENT'S
GIULIANI SAYS HE'S NOT
ANYTHING ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
JAKE, FEDERAL OFCIHEY
AR ANTICG HERE A
F OVER WHAT'S
ANNGICESEIZED BECAUSNO DOUBT GI
HERE IS SUBJECT TO
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVIL >> AL S .
JESSICA SCHN
MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN DEMOCRATIC
RK WARNE
CHAIR HE
COMMITTEE.
CHAIRMANTHOR JOININGWE'RE  B
NOT ISSU SINGLE SUBPOENA OAS
ASKED FOR INFORMATION.
SUSPICIONS OF GIULIANI'SACTI IE
T DO YOUAK INO
SIGNIFICANTLT BIG, T HOME
AND OFF THE ESRN,
OF THES THAT ARE ALSO
WRAPPED N THIS
>>EL AGAIN, I DON'
HAVE ANYTH
DEPARTMENT INVESTIONW THAT.
WE KNEW OVERR AGAM FIRSTIMPEACT
BIDENS, THAT HE CLEARLY AND I
FELT THIS WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I VOTE THE IMPEACH
OUR AMBAOR.IME WASAKING
OBVIOUSLY THE PHONE CALL BETWEEN
TRUMP AND THUKRAINIAT WAS
RUDY GIULIANI,E  LAC
FOZPE KNEW ALL
THIS A YEAR AG
GI I MIGHT
NG T WHAS NOW BECOMEY VIOUS,GEN
SPREAD PART OF TIRDISINFORTIT
JOE BIDEN HOUT THE WHO
LLJAKE, THAT THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF REPUB
SENATORS WHO WOULD GO TO
GIULIANI OTHERS IN THEMPK OFF,
OR MANIPULATED AND
WE ARE, YOU FOUR,X MONTHSFT.
ELECTION A STILL
PLEADING GUESS
IGNORAESS ISS  INVESTIGA H A SE
WARRAND ASSISTANT.
THS SEEM TO BE
SOMEONE WHO HAS NOSTFOREIGN LAB
DEEMED A BUREAUCRATIC PERWORIME
>>'M LEGAL PARTMENT IS DOING, B
SAIDETF OUR
ON THAT THE JUSTICE NT KIND OF
RAID O APROMINENNE WHO HAD
BEEN A FORME A
SOMEONE  ACTG AS RUMP'S
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HIT PRETT
HIGH BAR OF CERTAINTY E
THAT AION,, AGAIN, IT'S
HE PUB HAPPEIN TERMSF HI
INVOLVEMENT WITH THEAI., A
WITH THAT FOWAG HE  EVEN
NTD SI FAIRLY EVIDEN
LOTS OF PUBLICEP, A  ANDDISIMA A